what's going on guys
Justice League a lot of info dropped
this week details changes surprises
we're gonna unpack a lot of that stuff
right here right now we got a couple
awesome comic book aficionados to talk
about it with first oh he's an old
friend of the show he's a writer for DC
Comics he writes that woman Wonder Woman
77 welcome back mark and Draco
you've read me him and he's the coast of
superhero news he also does graphics for
screen junkies a friend of the family
Adam lavich before we get into all of
this news I want to go back a month and
a half or so and ask about Geoff Johns
co-head of DC films one of the cool
things about Geoff Johns
he is a true died Lowell comic book guy
oh hey I know he's Louie he's got DC in
his DNA I mean he loves these characters
Jeff comes from a place of positivity
and you know and like this or that
idealize what DC as DC you used to be
known on in the comic books is the
bright version of the Marvel Universe
hat you know and and in film are they
flip-flopped I think the great thing
about Jeff Jones is rebirth to me just
from reading it from a lot of
conversations I've had with people it's
kind of DC's apology from where the
comics kind of went in the new 52 and
and rebirth is kind of bringing it back
to like you're saying the lightness the
inspiration which DC has always been so
I think that's so key in and that's
something that we've seen it's
completely been seen in the flash
mentioning the flash there are wonderful
light moments throughout the TV show and
it seems like Ezra Miller's flash is
going to bring some of that lightness
into the DC cinematic I think I wait
does the Ezra Miller's interpretation
the scenes they've described from the
press the press they got to go to the
Justice League movie it sounds like he's
going to be the spider-man of three of
the Justice League the guy that's making
the quips and that is a scene where I
guess uh Bruce Wayne shows up at Barry
Allen's house and says basically look at
this video look at this video know who
you are and say I'm not that and then
Bruce Wayne throws a Batarang and if it
becomes slow and flash catches it yeah
he's like wait a minute you're Batman
and I guess the last line that the flesh
has us keep this yeah and that right
there sums up ang from some of the stuff
that we were used to from the Knowland
Dark Knight yes one of the big
announcements is that Justice League is
no longer going to be two movies
it's gonna be one movie talk to me about
that decision you guys well that's like
the Avengers movie was going to be two
movies infinity watch I think when they
say they're only doing one Justice State
movie there's so many ways to interpret
that you know Zack Snyder's wife said
this is just the one that could mean
just for them and they're gonna move on
that doesn't mean they're DC's not going
to do another Justice League movie but
by doing self-contained movies I think
it makes it more palatable to the
average person on the street I'm sure
they're probably just gonna wait and see
how this movie does they really want to
focus on this first story and then if
it's very successful sure maybe if
people really uh engage with it then
they'll bring them on again to the
sequel but and we still have flash Zack
Wonder Woman I'm adding an Aquaman we'll
all be coming out before the sequel
Justice League we got a lot of plot
details about Justice League Batman and
Wonder Woman recruiting metahumans just
give us a quick description what is a
metahuman it's super is a superhero for
a couple of years Marvel and DC I had
tried to own the trademark to the word
superhero so metahuman was a term that
was in use when there was the debate
over the trademark yeah it's it's one of
those words that it really just means
that these are people who have abilities
that's all so a lot of people were
anticipating that Darkseid would be the
big bad in this movie but it turns out
it's going to be Steppenwolf what do we
know about Steppenwolf what we can tell
us a little bit about this character Oh
Sepinwall so New Gods character they
were created by Jack Kirby when he left
Marvel in the late 60s early 70s and
went over to DC he's basically
Darkseid's general he runs Darkseid's
army forces and the parademons and that
sort of thing yeah well that was the
deletes he came I think like two days
after the movie premiered and it's
basically Lex Luthor interacting with
this holographic form that they haven't
I don't know if they've necessarily have
a hundred percent said that is
Steppenwolf but it looks a little wet
exactly so that's gonna be interesting
and I I don't really think that Darkseid
is the character that you started
Justice League movie with I think you
build to that Steppenwolf is a great
stepping stone
he's also Darkseid's uncle and he leads
the entire army of Apocalypse so I think
the whole Shakespearean thing to then
absolutely every seven who knew God
follow-up question the dream sequence
and Batman V Superman tell me a little
bit more about that because I know for a
lot of the uninitiated that was a bit of
a confusing scene and that dream
sequence which might actually be a flash
to the future Bruce sees an Omega symbol
burnt into the ground that's
Darkseid's symbol he shoots these things
called Omega beams from his eyes other
parademons those flying guys those are
Darkseid's army there's a mutant bug
humanoid creatures those are all those
are his stock and those are his
stormtroopers
why weren't you sitting next to me
telling me this while the movie was
going on because I was enjoying the
movie by myself all right if you're
confused at all about mother boxes and
Darkseid and apocalypse and the kind of
the whole concept what's happening in
this movie they said that in the
beginning we're going to get a little
bit of a history lesson as to where the
mother box has come from possibly who
Steppenwolf and Darkseid are to some
extent and how these mother box has gone
to the hands of the Atlanteans the
Amazons that will hopefully help clear
up a lot of questions people might have
or confusion as to kind of what's
happening why the Easter Easter eggs and
Batman vs Superman are actually Easter
eggs do me a favor simply explain to our
viewers what a mother boxes a mother box
is essentially this miniature
supercomputer that can create boom tubes
which allows characters like Darkseid to
travel between apocalypse and Earth and
they also have like all kinds of
different detection abilities and stuff
like that
okay I want to ask about this big info
release and how they've been really
transparent with this process now Batman
V Superman somewhat of a divisive film
you have people that loved it you have
people that thought it was you know not
the greatest effort it seems like they
invited a lot of their harshest critics
for this set visit well I think it's
brave of them I think the fact that the
Warner Brothers is investing billions of
dollars into the Cinematic Universe and
saying look maybe you're right maybe
there was stuff that wasn't great that
wasn't great about the movie and taking
the people they're not the not the
people that love their movies they
didn't invite me to the set they're
inviting these people that were the most
critical and showing them look we listen
to you and I think that that in the long
run is going to be super beneficial for
DC because it means that they pay
attention to the fans and value the fans
opinions I think what they're trying to
do is they're trying to really sell
hopefully a positive image of this movie
to us now that way it doesn't cause such
an uphill battle for movies like Suicide
Squad I think it's also worth mentioning
that you know people always say that
they shouldn't try to make these DC
movies so kid-friendly but not for kids
now they should make it for adults I
feel like it should they should they're
not necessarily kids movies but they're
but you can still include kids in these
movies nobody wants a rated G Justice
League movie obviously but it should be
accessible to everybody does it seem
like
Mack Snyder's role has changed or maybe
are they keeping him on a shorter leash
what do you think I honestly like I give
Zach Snyder credit for sticking around
Zack Snyder admits that there was so
much blowback and it kind of took him
off guard but he's still sticking with
it I feel like that's pretty commendable
and I don't give him a lot of credit for
staying around to get millions of
dollars well I mean just to have that
much backlash integer I have to sit
there and now figure out like okay how
do we rework this so everybody loves it
he's getting a lot of hate and jonno and
and probably too much okay let me pull
back and ask sort of a larger question
about the world here with the promotion
of Jeff Jones with the seemingly
lightening of the tone and then making
Justice League a single film instead of
what was going to be a two-parter do we
feel that is a little bit of a knee-jerk
course correction by them going by the
critical reaction of Batman V Superman
or is just the natural evolution of
things I don't think when you're dealing
with $300 300 million dollar movies
there's any knee-jerk reactions I think
a lot of this stuff is you know like
with the the reshoots for the Suicide
Squad all these big-budget movies do
tons of research months before they open
because they test them they see what
works and what doesn't
now it just becomes press and as the in
it you know the internet goes you say
something and then it becomes fact retro
actively so I think they took into
account the reaction absolutely they'd
be foolish not to I think at some point
it was inevitable that this DC Universe
was going to shift Chris Terrio talked
about it months ago I just step by step
they're going to move towards a lighter
tone so I think that it was a it was a
long-term game plan but I think now they
really felt like they had to put they
had to hit the gas a little sooner than
they expected maybe and this kind of
info dump we've gotten in the past a
week or so this is just the beginning
because at Comic Con we're going to get
to see some of this stuff right I would
imagine those local scenes that they
showed the press here that we'll see in
Hall age okay one last question how
scary are those JK Simmons pictures at
the gun show body was play Commissioner
Gordon but he looks like Bane pictures
right Batman in his final version I
thought those were the best photoshopped
picture eyes I've ever seen I believe
though that's his head on someone else's
body
I hear he looks like he's pulled right
out of the animated series so it's like
between seeing how ripped he is
and hearing that I'm like I'm in so guys
what do you think about all this news
what are you most excited about what are
you a little bit nervous about let us
know in the comments section we want to
know what you think I got to thank a
couple of awesome guest mark and Draco
Adam Bhavik thanks for being here fellas
and breaking down dropping some
knowledge on us
always a pleasure always pleasure thanks
for having me and thank you for watching
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye I don't often cry movies that
montage absolutely killed me the rest of
the movie wasn't as good as the first
ten minutes so I'm gonna go with
ratatouille yeah we're gonna have to go
into hiding after I know it's Pixar's
fault they made too many good movies